who needs a script when you have
impeccable improvisation skills these
are the marvel moments where actors
added their own taste to a scene in some
cases quite literally let's find out
which actors went completely off script
number one natalie portman and tessa
thompson really put the love in thor
love and thunder they had great
chemistry on set which led to the two
improvising together so a lot of the
stuff didn't actually exist on the page
a hand grenade no it's a portable
speaker there's something that we found
together and found with taika they
particularly enjoyed improvising during
their heartfelt scene where we really
saw the two characters bond
number 2.
star lord or star of improv chris pratt
thrived on the set of thor love and
thunder as his improv skills impressed
co-star chris hemsworth the guy is
wildly impressive with the spontaneity
and the humor and the things he comes up
with it's both funny inspiring and
intimidating hopefully we see the
asgardians of the galaxy together again
sometime soon
number three quick you need a weapon to
defend yourself with grab the bread that
must have been zendaya's thought process
during this improvised moment in
spider-man no way home when andrew
garfield's peter first shows up
zendaya's mj starts throwing bread at
him at first she was picking up
different objects like candlesticks then
after several takes she reached for the
bread and asked can i just throw bread
at him director john watts approved and
the moment was born
number four the scarlet witch is scary
but even scarier is an angry elizabeth
olsen when wanda's alternate universe
children are throwing objects at her in
multiverse a madness one of them
accidentally hit elizabeth olsen in the
face eliciting a genuine yell from the
actor stop it the moment scared the poor
kid actors but resulted in very
realistic reactions
number five shanghi director destin
daniel creighton was very open to
letting his actors improv on set which
led to aquafina and simul liu working
their own dialogue into the film a lot
of the banter between the two characters
was improvised as aquafina stated that
it was her goal to get the cameraman to
laugh as often as possible
number six if the love between the three
spider-man in no way home felt real it's
because it was andrew garfield telling
the other spider-man he loves them
wasn't part of the script and was added
by garfield and it had nothing to do
with the characters and everything to do
with how he felt about his co-stars that
was just me loving them
number seven when you get three
spider-men on the same screen it's a
requirement that they all point at each
other to fulfill the great meme prophecy
andrew garfield is the one that came up
with the perfect moment to do so the
school lab scene originally had the
three spider-men answering ned's hey
peter with a simple yeah but garfield
saw it as the perfect opportunity to
incorporate the meme and everyone agreed
number eight did you know that willem
dafoe is something of an improver
himself so much so that he did over 30
takes of the same scene when the goblin
is taunting peter in his apartment that
was all dafoe who gave a different
performance for all 30 takes holland
said he had never worked with an actor
who gave the director so many options
number nine elena's mocking of natasha's
posing actually came from florence pugh
mocking the poses in real life pew
learned that the black widow poses would
result in breaking every bone in your
body in real life pugh pointed this out
to scarlett johansson and started making
fun of her on set this eventually led to
her character mocking the posing in the
movie it's a fighting pose you're a
total poser you're a poser
number 10 owen wilson and tom hiddleston
were a perfect match together on screen
the two would often improv together
during loki bouncing off one another one
of these moments was when tom hiddleston
decided to straighten out owen wilson's
tie during a take it was a small moment
but it perfectly represented the dynamic
between the two characters
number 11
bye bye miss american pie have you
checked out this david harbor improv guy
harbor singing the classic song to
florence pew was completely improvised
he thought it was a great way to show
how his character really did care about
elena even if he wasn't the best father
so he brings up the song basically as
him saying i tried
number 12 doctor strange telling peter
that he loves him in no way home was an
improvised moment by benedict
cumberbatch they were having a difficult
time coming up with the right thing to
say to make the moment work cumberbatch
came up with the line during reshoots
and it was the perfect ingredient needed
to make the scene complete
number thirteen when you put anthony
mackie and sebastian stan in the same
room you can't expect anything less than
chaotic kid energy a lot of their banter
throughout the show was off the cuff
thinking by the two for example their
therapy scene when they sit face to face
was all improvised when it came to
getting a scene done and letting the two
actors go off script director carrie
skoglin said you just have to let him
ride he would talk less exactly what i
was gonna say
number 14 we think some of the best
moments from miss marvel were when the
family was just being a family their
dynamic was so natural and that's
because they were allowed to infuse
improv into their scenes zenobia shroff
who plays kamala's mom said it best when
it came to improvising sometimes you
just do it and it lands funny in your
delivery or something
number 15 florence pew was definitely
hungry when filming her scene with haley
steinfeld in hawkeye steinfeld wasn't
initially going to throw a hot sauce
bottle hi
but they found it on set and thought it
was perfect which worked out because
florence pew loves hot sauce like really
loves hot sauce it was her idea to douse
her mac and cheese with it and she had
no problem continuously eating copious
amounts of the stuff take after take
number 16 how exactly does one define
what candy is the scene between loki and
mobius when loki notes grapes and nuts
as candy and mobius responds
you're so bitter was nowhere to be found
in the script it's such a small moment
of improvisation and yet it nails the
dynamic of the two characters
number 17 today is your turn to improv
jake lockley speaking in spanish in the
post-credits scene of moon knight
was an addition made by oscar isaac he
thought it gave lockley a distinctive
trait that separated himself from mark
and steven isaac helped craft the
characters throughout the series and
this is just one of the many ways he
gave them unique personalities he's a
storyteller first and foremost and that
was just one of the many contributions
he made to this series
number 18 jonathan magers was truly the
kang of improv in this scene majors
explaining what all his variants said to
each other when they first met wasn't
scripted nor was when kang gets up and
stands on his desk the team just kept
filming and allowed majors to do his
thing
number 19 loki gave us another another
this was a reference to the first thor
movie when thor yells the line and
smashes his drink the moment in loki
however wasn't in the script it was
improvised by tom hiddleston
who thought it would be a great callback
to his character's brother hiddleston
proved he is a true fan of the mcu with
this callback
number 20 kingpin is one of the most
intimidating unpredictable and scary
villains in the mcu which is why you'll
find it oddly heartwarming that he's a
little laughing hawkeye when he pinches
a young maya's cheeks was genuine he
found young actress darnell besos so
adorable that he couldn't help but let
out a little giggle and the filmmakers
decided to keep it in the show
number 21
moon knight is cool confident and can
handle himself in any situation steven
grant's mr knight is the complete
opposite this is why oscar isaac decided
to have steven clumsily fall over when
he first summons the suit he thought the
moment perfectly suited the character
and we would have to agree
number 22 jeremy renner and hailey
steinfeld had no problem finding their
chemistry on the set of hawkeye
a lot of the banter between the two was
improvised and they had a blast filming
together one improvised moment that
stands out is when the two hold an arrow
together it was originally supposed to
be a simple dialogue scene between the
two but ended up being one of the best
moments in the show
number 23 show us those dance moves
zemo's dance moves impressed everyone
when they first saw him jamming out on
the dance floor so much so that marvel
released a full hour-long version of the
groovin zemo the dance was improvised by
zemo actor daniel brone who had a great
time coming up with the funky moves
broll admitted the moves aren't his own
as he has a much different style of
dancing in real life this is zemo style
number 24 breakups are tough especially
when you're the god of thunder thor
weakly claiming that his split up with
jane was mutual was an improvised moment
by chris hemsworth he said he couldn't
remember the reason they actually broke
up so he just uttered this hilarious
line instead she didn't dump me you know
i dumped her some mutual dumping sure
thor we believe you
number 25 no one is just gonna forget
that you went the space peter parker
nick fury made a very good point when he
pointed out that the friendly
neighborhood spider-man had in fact been
to space before
that was all samuel l jackson who came
up with the line on the spot jake
gyllenhaal loved jackson's improv energy
and can confirm the iconic line came
straight from jackson himself it was
improvised i'm here to attest
the mcu may be the most meticulously
planned franchise in the history of
movies but sometimes the most magical
moments come completely off the cuff
which improvised moment was your
favorite let us know in the comments and
thanks for stopping by at the things